[Musik]
drohkulisse an der ukrainischen grenze
mehr als 100.000 soldaten schwere waffen
und panzer soll russland dort
stationiert haben und der aufmarsch geht
weiter berichten westliche
nachrichtendienste
herzlich willkommen zu einem zdf spezial
droht eine invasion russlands in die
ukraine russland bestreitet eingriffs
pläne sieht sich selbst bedroht und
fordert eine zusage dass die ukraine
nicht teil der nato wird nach wird
weiter verhandelt die diplomatie ist in
vollem gange aber hell dass putin zurück
wie groß ist die kriegsgefahr in europa
bevor wir mit expertinnen darüber reden
cornelia donath mit einem rückblick auf
einen schon seit jahren schwelende
konflikt
die krise beginnt als der ukrainische
präsident viktor janukowitsch auf druck
des kremls ein quasi fertiges
assoziierungsabkommen mit der eu auf eis
liegt und sich russland zuwendet
hunderttausende gehen daraufhin auf die
straße vor allem auf dem majdan dem
unabhängigkeitsplatz in kiew
die lage eskaliert mehr als 100 menschen
sterben bei straßenkämpfen
präsident janukowitsch taucht unter und
flieht nach russland der konflikt
verlagert sich auf die halbinsel krim
die zu mehr als der hälfte von russen
bewohnt ist separatisten besetzen das
parlament in der hauptstadt simferopol
kiew wirft dem kreml eine bewaffnete
invasion der krim vor
in einem umstrittenen referendum stimmen
die krim bewohner über einen beitritt zu
russland ab offiziell sprechen sich mehr
als 95 prozent dafür aus die eu und die
usa verhängen daraufhin sanktionen gegen
russland ungeachtet dessen
volksfeststimmung in moskau
die krim ist heimgekehrt
war die annexion der krim nur der anfang
im osten der ukraine kommt es zu
gewaltsamen ausschreitungen in lohans
grundton jetzt besetzen pro-russische
separatisten verwaltungsgebäude und
rufen unabhängige volksrepublik 'nen aus
petro poroschenko gewinnt nach
janukowitschs flucht die
präsidentschaftswahl er ist klar pro
europäisch verkündet den krieg beenden
zu wollen und einen eu-beitritt
anzustreben russland droht darauf mit
ernsten konsequenzen
eine boeing von malaysia airlines stürzt
über der ost ukraine ab alle 298
menschen an bord sterben regierung und
russische separatisten werfen sich
gegenseitig vor das flugzeug
abgeschossen zu haben
internationale ermittler sind überzeugt
er 17 wurde von einer rakete der
separatisten getroffen geliefert von
russland
der westen verschärft seine sanktionen
gegen russland doch das töten in der ost
ukraine geht weiter
bei friedensverhandlungen in minsk
vermitteln deutschland und frankreich im
rahmen des nummern die format zwischen
den staatschefs putin und poroschenko in
einer marathon-sitzung einigt man sich
auf eine waffenruhe
die allerdings nicht hält
es kommt zu offenen militärischen
konfrontation
die russische küstenwache beschießt drei
ukrainische marineschiffe in der
meerenge von kertsch
mehrere seeleute werden festgenommen
einige sind verletzt der vorwurf
eindringen in russisches hoheitsgewässer
politikneuling und komiker wolodimir
selensky wird neuer präsident der
ukraine
er verspricht reformen und den konflikt
im osten des landes beizulegen außerdem
kündigte er neue friedensgespräche mit
russland an doch auch er kann an der
situation nichts ändern bis heute hat
der konflikt 13.000 tote gefordert
im frühjahr und im herbst zieht russland
an der grenze zur ukraine bis zu 100.000
soldaten zusammen kiew und die
nato-partner befürchten ab jetzt eine
russische invasion in der ukraine
zugeschaltet ist mir jetzt die russland
expertin sabine fischer guten
tag aus berlin wo fischer für wie
wahrscheinlich halten sie denn ein
einmarsch russlands in die ukraine
ich denke es gibt hier unterschiedliche
szenarien
von
einem einmarsch der tatsächlich größeres
größere teil des ukrainischen
territoriums betreffen würde über einen
einmarsch in die jetzt schon
umstrittenen gebiete in die jetzt und
lohans bis hin zu hybriden verstärkt
übrigen maßnahmen um die politische
situation in der ukraine zu
destabilisieren ich halte einen groß
angelegten einmarsch militärischen
einmarsch russlands in die ukraine nach
wie vor für
recht unwahrscheinlich auch weil die
kosten dafür enorm hoch werden während
aber ich denke wir müssen uns darauf
einstellen dass ist zu russischen
eingriffen und angriffen auf den in die
ukraine kommt in den in den kommenden
wochen und monaten was will denn
eigentlich putin was bezweckt der ihrer
meinung nach mit der drohkulisse
also es ist tatsächlich eine
militärische drohkulisse die hier
ausgebaut worden ist über einen längeren
zeitraum um bestimmte ziele zu erreichen
auf der ebene des russisch-ukrainischen
konflikt geht es hier um die umsetzung
der minister vereinbarungen von 2014/15
im russischen st in
und um so zu sagen ja die bewahrung
russischer kontrolle über vor allen
dingen die ukrainische die orientierung
der ukrainischen außenpolitik
und das führt dann gleich auf die
nächste ebene und das ist tatsächlich
die ebene der europäischen sicherheit
russland hat im dezember 2021 also vor
anderthalb monaten zwei vertragsentwürfe
vorgelegt mit den usa mit der nato in
denen es letztendlich tatsächlich um
eine neuordnung europäischer sicherheit
im russischen sinne geht um die
errichtung und dann auch eben
schriftlich bestätigte und akzeptierte
juristisch verbindliche akzeptanz von
einflusszone
und das sind dann eben die weiter
greifenden ziele die die russische seite
mit unter anderem diese militärischen
aufmarsch an der russisch-ukrainischen
grenze jetzt verfolgt mehr also die nato
verweist dagegen auf das
selbstbestimmungsrecht jedes landes
russland fordert dass die ukraine nicht
mitglied der nato wird wie könnte denn
da überhaupt ein kompromiss aussehen
genau also das sind letztendlich hat
russland im dezember drei forderungen
gestellt das eine ist tatsächlich dass
die nato jeder art von
erweiterungspolitik
einstellen muss das zweite ist der
rückbau der nato der militärischen
infrastruktur der nato auf den zustand
vor 1997 also vor den erweiterungsrunde
runden die dann eingesetzt haben und bis
dritte ziel ist es sind eine reihe von
vertrauensbildung und transparenz und
kommunikationsmaßnahmen zwischen
russland und
der nato und tatsächlich ist es so und
deshalb jetzt auch zum beispiel die die
amerikanische antwort auf diese
russischen vertragsentwürfe die gelegt
worden ist heute vormittag von der
spanischen zeitung el país gezeigt kann
die westliche seite vor allen dingen
diesen dritten court also transparenz
maßnahmen vertrauens bildungsmaßnahmen
maßnahmen bereich rüstungskontrolle und
abrüstung etc verhandeln und will das
auch um eben zu einer
verbesserung der der europäischen
sicherheits situation zu kommen aber im
hinblick auf die russische forderung
dass die nato ihre open der protokoll
ist sie also die politik der offenen
offenen tür aufgeben soll da ist aus
nato perspektiven auch aus
amerikanischer perspektive eben kaum ein
kompromiss möglich
einzelne nato-staaten wollen anders als
deutschland ihre militärhilfe für die
ukraine erhöhen wird sich der konflikt
dadurch entschärfen oder wird er eher
eskalieren
das ist eine frage der perspektive also
es geht hier tatsächlich in erster linie
darum die verteidigungsfähigkeit der
ukraine zu unterstützen und dadurch die
möglichen kosten die russland entstünden
sollte es sich tatsächlich zu einem
einmarsch zu einem zu einem weiteren
militärischen angriff entscheiden in die
höhe zu treiben also das ist
letztendlich
wird das gesehen aus der perspektive
dieser dieser nato staaten als
präventionsmaßnahme um einen russischen
angriff vorzugreifen wie wird sich denn
die verlegung von weiteren us truppen
nach europa auswirkungen auch in diesem
sinne
es ist mit sicherheit in diesem sinne
gedacht die das russische narrativ das
habe ich vorhin schon angedeutet geht in
eine ganz andere richtung und natürlich
wird dieser schritt in russland in
moskau entsprechend auch interpretiert
werden welche rolle spielt deutschland
denn überhaupt in dem konflikt
deutschland spielt von anfang an in
diesem konflikt eine sehr sehr große
rolle sie haben es in ihrem beitrag
jetzt gerade selbst auch gezeigt also
deutschland war von anfang an
2014/15 als als zentrale verhandler
vermittler in diesem konflikt aktiv
angela merkel hat zusammen mit françois
hollande dem russischen präsidenten und
dem ukrainischen präsident die minsker
vereinbarungen verhandeln und war immer
eine sehr wichtige ansprechpartner für
alle beteiligten im konflikt und eben
auch für die westlichen verbündeten
deutschland hat eine sehr wesentliche
rolle gespielt
beim zustandekommen der sanktions pakete
die dann gegen russland in anschlag
gebracht worden sind 2014/15 und
teilweise eben auch zur deeskalation
der unmittelbaren kriegshandlungen in
der ost ukraine beigetragen haben also
hier spielt und hat auch sehr stark mit
daran gewirkt dass das dieser sanktions
konsens innerhalb der eu
aufrechterhalten erhalten worden ist
seitdem also deutschland hat eine sehr
zentrale rolle in diesem konflikt und in
den verhandlungen über den contact und
vielleicht kurz nach worauf sollten wir
uns für die nächsten tage wochen
einstellen
die internationalen bemühungen den
konflikt zu entschärfen werden natürlich
weiter gehen das ist auch sehr wichtig
worauf wir uns einstellen sollen ist
sehr schwierig vorherzusagen ich habe
einfach eingangs schon gesagt es gibt
mehrere mögliche szenarien
letztendlich wird im kreml und von
wladimir putin selbst entschieden werden
wie russland am ende handelt und wie
russland darauf reagiert dass eben die
westliche seite sich auch dauerhaft
nicht auf diese maximale forderungen die
aus moskau kamen im dezember
einlassen wird und wie diese
entscheidung ausfallen wird können wir
schlicht und ergreifend nicht wissen
dass hat vor allen dingen zu tun mit der
intransparenz und der extremen
personalisierung dieses russischen
entscheidungsprozesses deswegen ist es
ebenso wichtig dass man ganz
unterschiedliche szenarien durch denkt
und die möglichen konsequenzen
mitdenkt und eben auch im sinne von
handlungsnotwendigkeiten die dann
entstehen vielen dank sabine fischer weg
nach berlin vielen dank
[Musik]
ja auch die osteuropäischen nato
mitglieder machen sich inzwischen sorgen
die nato verstärkt deshalb die truppen
im osten in der ukraine selbst aber
sollen keine nato soldaten kämpfen auch
wenn die ukrainische armee jetzt
militärisch aufgerüstet wird das
kräfteverhältnis zwischen russland und
der ukraine ist eindeutig armin coerper
und michael strompen berichten
diese bilder hat die welt monatelang
gesehen russland fährt schwere geschütze
auf an der grenze zur ukraine
frei zugängliche satellitenbilder
belegen dass
kriegs bereit aufgereiht hunderte panzer
artillerie geschosse haubitzen aber auch
unterkünfte kantinen krankenstationen
für weit über 100000 mann und
kapazitäten für viele mehr der polnische
militär analyst konrad musiker hat die
karten erstellt und ausgewertet
das sind keine übungen keine strategie
manöver was die da tun ist
offensichtlich sie bereiten sich auf
einen krieg vor
musiker identifiziert
36 raketenabschussrampen vom typ
iskander mit über 500 kilometer
reichweite
außerdem theo es mehrfach raketenwerfer
besonders geeignet zur eroberung großer
städte und panzer vom typ t 90
die russen haben natürlich das
militärische potenzial die ukrainische
armee zu überwältigen aber das müssen
sie erstmal tun also dass das ein
einseitiger kampf ist das ist auch klar
dass das relativ schnell in eine art
guerillakrieg stadtguerilla
unkonventioneller widerstand übergehen
wird ist auch klar aber der wird
stattfinden
darauf setzen vor allem die amerikaner
seit wochen liefern sie munition und
leichte panzer abwehrsysteme an die
ukraine in moskau sieht man das als
provokation kiew nutze die waffen im
kampf gegen die prorussischen
separatisten im don pass
jeder einzelne waffe ob defensiv oder
offensiv nutzt den heißspornen im tief
bei dieser operation
wir müssen darüber in sorge sein und
haben das lange kommen sehen
seit acht jahren kämpft die 200.000
soldaten starke armee der ukraine gegen
die separatisten im donbass und konnte
bisher kaum mehr als ein patt erreichen
ich will dass das hier aufhört wir haben
einfach genug
die russische armee verfügt über zehn
mal mehr soldaten und es vor allem aus
der luft deutlich überlegen über eine
luftabwehr die dem gewachsen wäre
verfügt die ukraine nämlich nicht
da fragen wir unsere brüssel und nato
korrespondentin anne gellinek für wie
wahrscheinlich hält denn die nato die
gefahr eines einmarsches russlands die
nato stützt sich natürlich in erster
linie auf die geheimdienstquellen ihrer
mitglieder und da in erster linie auf
die der amerikaner und die sagen dass es
einen sehr sehr deutlichen
truppenaufmarsch an der grenze zur
ukraine gibt der nicht mit einer
normalen militärübung zu erklären ist
denn die russischen denn die russischen
die russen das russische militär hat
eben auch kampftruppen dorthin verlegt
auch militär hospitäler außerdem gibt es
auch eine übung in weißrussland in
belarus wenn man auf die karte guckt
dann sieht man dass das sehr nahe
nördlich an kiew ist also es gibt ein
bedrohungsszenario was die geheimdienste
hier sehen das deutlich nicht mit einer
militärübung sowie die russen sie
behaupten zu erklären ist und vor allem
sehen sie dass dieser truppenaufmarsch
immer weiter geht dass die russische
regierung nicht deeskaliert sondern eben
immer weiter soldaten dorthin schickt
wie groß ist denn die drohkulisse die
die nato aufbaut wie würde man denn im
falle eines krieges reagieren na die
nato wiederholt ständig dass sie
natürlich ein verteidigungsbündnis ist
und dass sie versucht einen möglichen
einmarsch russlands in die ukraine
erstmals zu verhindern und in erster
linie durch abschreckung und dialog die
abschreckung sieht man in den letzten
tagen die nato-verbündeten also
besonders die länder im westen der nato
versuchen die östlichen verbündeten zu
unterstützen mit militärhilfe also zum
beispiel belgien und die niederlande
haben kampfflieger geschickt die spanier
schicken ein schiff man versucht also so
zu zeigen wir sind da wir unterstützen
die westlichen bündnispartner aber im
falle eines einmarschs von russland in
die ukraine würde die nato als militär
binden bündnis nicht eingreifen denn die
ukraine ist kein nato mitglied und die
usa haben diese option eines
militärischen eingreifens in der ukraine
schon ganz zu anfang vom tisch genommen
in moskau wird er nicht müde zu
behaupten dass russland kein aggressor
sei und keinerlei absichten habe die
ukraine zu überfallen wie glaubhaft ist
das denn
also im nato-hauptquartier in brüssel
findet man diese these überhaupt nicht
glaubhaft denn wenn man sich die jüngste
geschichte ansieht dann sieht man ja
dass nicht die ukraine russland bedroht
sondern im gegenteil russland die krim
annektiert hat russland die separatisten
gebiete im osten der ukraine weiterhin
bis heute mit waffen unterstützt und
russland hybride angriffe auf die
ukraine und den westen
westeuropa durchführt also hier ist
glaube ich ganz klar wer der aggressor
ist und wer bedroht wird russland
behauptet sogar umgekehrt dass die nato
mit ihrer ausdehnung weit in den osten
der eigentliche aggressor sei und moskau
sich deshalb bedroht fühlt wie behandelt
man diese argumentation ja das war ganz
interessant wird die mir putin hat ja
gestern eine zusammen mit viktor orban
eine pressekonferenz gegeben und da
hatte dieses szenario der bedrohung noch
einmal wiederholt und auch ausgeführt er
hat noch mal die inzwischen lang
widerlegte these wiederholt dass die
nato ja versprochen habe sich nicht nach
osten aus zu drehen auszudehnen dieses
versprechen findet sich in keiner
schriftlichen akte dass weißrussland
natürlich auch aber er hat gesagt die
usa wollten russland in einen
bewaffneten konflikt hineinziehen als er
hat ganz deutlich gemacht dass russland
sich bedroht fühlt jetzt ist die frage
nur bei der nato und auch im ganzen
westen ist das ein szenario an das
latino putin wirklich glaubt oder ist es
eines was er sozusagen als vorwand nimmt
um eben doch militärisch in der ukraine
zu agieren hier rätseln alle über die
wahren motive aber ganz klar ist dass
russland weiter behauptet es werde
bedroht von der nato was natürlich de
facto nicht der fall ist wenn man sich
die blanken zahlen anguckt und sieht
dass 100.000 soldaten an der grenze zur
ukraine stehen und die nato-truppen in
osteuropa sind vielleicht 20.000 man
wenn's ganz hoch kommt vielen dank anne
gellinek
der westen droht unterdessen auch mit
wirtschaftlichen sanktionen
doch ist wirklich alles auf dem tisch
vom internationalen zahlungsverkehr
swift bis zur gaspipeline nord stream 2
da vermittelt man dann putin auf das
signal der uneinigkeit svenja bergerhoff
über für und wider der möglichen
sanktionen
keine sanktionsmöglichkeit wäre russland
aus dem internationalen
finanztransaktionen swift
auszuschließen diese sanktion würde
russlands exporthandel deutlich
schwächen
doch gilt der ausschluss wegen seiner
immensen auswirkungen auf die
weltwirtschaft auch als wirtschaftlicher
atombombe eben weil die welt gerne mit
russland handelt doch ohne geldströme
keine geschäfte russland generiert große
einnahmen aus dem export von öl und gas
es läge nahe die ostseepipeline nord
stream zwei als sanktion nicht in
betrieb zu nehmen das könnte ja
weiterhin über andere pipelines nach
europa geführt werden einige westliche
länder wie die usa oder frankreich
würden diesen schritt begrüßen sind sie
doch schon lange gegner des vorhabens
doch es spricht auch einiges dagegen
könnte russland als antwort den gashahn
zudrehen deutschland ganz europa und
russland sind jedoch stark voneinander
abhängig
55 prozent des gases in deutschland
kommt aus russland und andersherum
85 prozent des gases dass russland per
pipeline exportiert geht nach europa und
alternativer gaseinkauf europas zb aus
den usa wäre deutlich teurer und ist
umstritten denn in den usa darf das auch
mittels fracking gewonnen werden einigen
könnte man sich wahrscheinlich einfacher
auf kleinere sanktionspaket wie zb das
einfrieren einzelner konnten russische
oligarchen oder maßnahmen gegen einzelne
russische banken neuer im sanktionen
potpourri
exportbeschränkungen beispielsweise für
computerchips die auf amerikanischer
technologie basieren diese dürften dann
nicht mehr nach russland geliefert
werden diese maßnahme würde die
weiterentwicklung und modernisierung der
russischen wirtschaft vermutlich
effektiv hemmen
schattenseite dieser maßnahme für die
westliche wirtschaft technik hersteller
könnten keine geräte mehr nach russland
liefern genauso autohersteller denn auch
in den modernen fahrzeugen sind viele
computer chips verbaut
kann man sich auf gar nichts einigen
wäre auch ein alleingang der usa denkbar
viele internationale geschäfte werden in
us dollar getätigt die vereinigten
staaten könnten russland den zugang zum
dollar verwehren und auch so putins
wirtschaft angreifen
fazit sanktionen bringen komplexe
probleme wegen verschiedener nationaler
interessen der westlichen länder am ende
wird man sehen auf welchen gemeinsamen
nenner der westen überhaupt kommen kann
und zugeschaltet ist nun die
wirtschaftsexperten claudia kempfert
guten tag guten tag ich grüße mit
welcher sanktionen könnte denn der
westen russland am meisten treffen
die die stärkste waffe sage ich mal als
sanktion natürlich tief fossilen
energien die wir ja immer noch in europa
aber auch weltweit nutzen und sehr viel
von russland importieren das sehr
wichtige handelsströme gerade für
russland weil dort sehr hohe einnahmen
generiert werden also je früher je
schneller es uns gelingt auch auf
fossile energien zu verzichten
beziehungsweise auch die importe aus
russland desto am meisten könnte man
russland treffen und umgekehrt womit
könnte russland vor allem die europa und
insbesondere deutschland wirtschaftlich
am stärksten schaden ja man sieht ja im
moment das szenario was recht gut
funktioniert aus russischer sicht
nämlich
gaslieferungen gleich zu drosseln bzw
auch unsicherheiten zu schüren führte
dazu dass der gaspreis massiv nach oben
gegangen ist und wir alle spüren es ja
schon nicht nur die heizkosten die sich
ja massiv erhöhen auch für die
wirtschaft für die industrie ist das ein
erheblicher kostenfaktor
also das ist das szenario was soll was
russland nutzt auch ein wenig und
profitiert auch im moment denn die
gaspreise ölpreise sind sehr sehr hoch
und russland exportiert von diesem güter
sehr sehr viele macht hohe einnahmen wie
stark sind wir dann von russischem gas
abhängig
wir sind recht stark abhängig
insbesondere deutschland weil wir in der
vergangenheit die abhängigkeit noch
erhöht haben über 50 prozent unseres
gases beziehen wir mittlerweile schon
aus russland das ist
verhältnismäßig viel in europa gab es
die strategie er die russischen
gaslieferungen zu reduzieren mehr auf
diversifikation zu setzen da hat
deutschland aber den konträren weg
gewählt und er noch mehr russische
gaslieferungen bezogen und deswegen sind
wir jetzt auch in dieser schwierigen
situation
nord stream 2 wurde ja von bundeskanzler
scholz vor kurzem noch als ein rein
privatwirtschaftliches projekt
bezeichnet ohne politische hintergründe
wie sehen sie das als energie expertin
es war nur ein reines
privatwirtschaftliches projekt wenn es
das gewesen wäre hätte sich nie gelohnt
wir haben da auch mal nachgerechnet wir
haben verschiedene studien dazu erstellt
und sehen einfach dass die
nord-stream-pipeline
unrentabel ist und wenn es nur privat
wirtschaftlicher wäre hätte man auch
diese schwierigkeiten nicht
geostrategische gründe spielten auch
immer eine rolle hier ging es ja von
anfang an auch darum die ukraine als
transitland zu umgehen das war von
anfang an klar deswegen war es ja auch
so konträr oder hat viel unmut auch
innerhalb europas ausgelöst oder auch
weltweit und das auch zu recht welche
alternative gäbe es denn zu russischem
gas für deutschland ja es gibt schon
alternativen also es gibt ja auch
alternative lieferländer die europa mit
gas beziehen kurzfristig ist das auch
sicherlich möglich da mehr zu beziehen
jetzt wenn es zu kompletten
lieferunterbrechungen kommen sollte also
es wir sind da in europa in deutschland
recht gut angeboten aber andere
europäische länder noch besser weil sie
mehr auf flüssiggas setzen und
flüssiggas zumindest ausgebaut haben und
damit eben auch eine bessere
flexibilität haben was die gas bezüge
angeht darauf können wir einerseits
setzen und andererseits haben wir auch
gefüllte gasspeicher in anderen
europäischen ländern wenn wir da gute
kooperieren können wieder den gasbedarf
über den winter decken aber es muss
perspektivisch darum gehen sich mehr und
mehr vom fossilen erdgas zu
verabschieden alles dafür zu tun um
erneuerbare energien auszubauen und das
energiesparen zu stärken und im großen
ganzen welche sanktionen kann
deutschland sich als exportnation
überhaupt leisten ohne sich selbst zu
schlagen
ja das ist immer ein
schwieriges unterfangen weil man ja wenn
man so denn ein führt auch da
gleichzeitig sich mit schadet also
sofern ist sie eher die frage welche
sanktionen müsste denn deutschland sich
leisten und in dem fall gilt es wohl
eher in richtung
energieimporte oder die noch sind zwei
pipeline die man jetzt eben nicht sofort
genehmigt und deswegen auch die den ein
druckmittel in der hand hat um russland
hier entsprechende auch zur handlung zu
bewegen vielen dank claudia kempfert
danke ihnen
ja welche signale sendet man dann
russland was kann will muss man sich an
möglichen sanktionen leisten diplomatie
und drohkulisse beides ist gefragt eine
spaltung europas hilft wohl nur eine
kleine mir putin
das war es von uns aktuelle
informationen jederzeit unter zdf heute
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]